Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my Full House of the Dragon Episode 7 video there
were a whole bunch of Easter Eggs and references
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel I'll be doing videos for all the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get them and
careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet we'll just start at the
beginning and work our way through shop by shot
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments as we
go along starting with the title of the episode
driftmark it's a reference to the island driftmark
obviously this is the seat of house velaryon where
high tide Castle is Corlys Velaryon rules this
house from there's a lot of talk of who it's going
to pass to because of all the different people
getting remarried because of all the deaths during
the episode and the question of people's birds and
legitimacy and if it wasn't clear by the end of
the episode they don't answer that question like
in the trailer for next week's episode there's
still talk of who's going to inherit driftmark so
that'll be going on in the background in addition
to all the main a-story Dance of the Dragons
blacks versus green stuff this was also the first
episode where someone literally actually referred
to them as the greens but no one's actually
referred to rhaenyra's side as the blacks yet
though but she was wearing black for the first
time in this episode so like they're wearing
their trademark colors in this big fight the only
minor change that I detected in the intro scene
here of the ancient Valyrian Freehold with all
the blood flowing from the different symbols is
the addition of baby Joffrey to rhaenyra's symbol
but I think they'll change it again in episode 8
to symbolize rhaenyra and Daemon's remarriage to
each other and eventually they will start having
children of their own too there were references
to that during the episode like she talked about
not being able to conceive with laenor right
before they got it on she also talked about
fighting fire with fire at the end of the episode
and the whole idea is the more Dragon Riders the
more dragon seeds you have the more kids you give
birth to the more dragons you potentially control
so just because there are a lot of kids flying
around on the show right now doesn't mean this
is the end there will be more kids in the future
the actual opening scene is of lano's burial
ceremony it's a barrel at sea per the customs of
the velaryon family the speech is being given by
her uncle corlys velaryon's younger brother
and during his speech because of the history
of their family in their ties with the sea a lot
of it is very see very ship themed he references
the Merling King that's the god of the sea most
commonly associated with the narrow sea where they
are he's mentioned in feasts for crows and a bunch
of the other Song of Ice and Fire novels they call
her passage to death her final voyage as in the
nine Voyages of corlys velaryon that's where all
the special trinkets all around his throne room
come from there was a spin-off show that they
were developing for corlys velaryon so they might
actually tell the stories of how he went on all
those nine voyages eventually at some point they
show you Otto Hightower who's returned because
he's since been named hand of the King again and
returned to King's Landing when Laena's Uncle says
that she and her family her children will always
be Bound in Blood that's also a metaphor for the
Targaryen family and their Valyrian blood as well
as foreshadowing for the end of the episode where
Daemon and ranera perform their marriage using
ancient valyrian customs of binding their blood
together they show you a wide shot of the high
tide Castle from a different View and they have
five dragons that we know up here there might be
more dragons in the background too but there's
caraxes Daemon's Dragon there's syrax rhaenyra's
Dragon seasmoke laenor's dragon I think meleys
is meant to be there his mother rhaenys dragon in
vhagar are obviously Laena's former Dragon because
vhagar obviously very important to the episode now
when team green leaves at the end of the episode
they have three dragons with them including vhagar
I'll address that in a second because I think they
might have had sunfyre aegon's Dragon also there
and they might have also had Helena's Dragon whose
dreamfyre that was the same dragon that almost
wound up killing Aemond we get Helena targaryen's
latest Dragon dream she says hand turns Loom spool
of green spool of black dragons of flesh weaving
dragons of thread that's meant to be a prophecy
about the actual Dance of the dragons like the
actual Targaryen Civil War the two different sides
the blacks and the greens actually going at each
other also while she's repeating her Dragon dream
that little spiders crawling all over her hand
that's meant to be a reference to Laris strong
who's kind of like a varys Littlefinger type of
person in this situation at the end of the episode
he also says Ah if you should ever need anything
I'd be happy to go get an eye for an eye and she's
like oh no I don't need you right now but I will
definitely need you in the future they have a
couple funny moments with aegon the second here
when he jokes about marrying Helena that's ironic
because alicent has already betrothed the two of
them and they will eventually get married and
have children like he's already supposed to get
married to her him eyeballing the servant girls
trying to go after them and getting low-key drunk
through the entire funeral is also right out of
the books he loved a drink that only got worse
as he got older and he also loved to get it on
with the servant girls also another really funny
ironic moment here is when aegon is talking about
fancying legs so to speak when he's talking about
Helena it's also a reference to Helena's other
Dragon Dream from last week's episode when she
says the last ring has no legs which is a dragon
dream about aegon II's future no spoilers there
but it definitely has something to do with legs
I don't think they're actually going to pay that
Dragon dream off till much much later like she had
a dragon dream about aemond he'll have to lose one
eye and they paid that off in this episode the
other one about aegon they probably won't pay
off till next season we get a couple scenes with
jacaerys and lucerys and baela and rhaena they're
actually pretty good friends they just want to
show you the vibe between Daemon's children and
raniera's children and it's generally pretty good
like they're on pretty good terms corlys velyaron
talking to lucerys about inheriting drift marks
someday is obviously a reference to everything
that goes on during the episode with laenor faking
his death and then the question of who's going to
inherit driftmark because the whole idea of
who has the greatest right like rhaenyra is
children who everybody knows are bastards or is it
going to be someone within the velaryon family and
that's just one of those plot lines that'll take
a couple more episodes maybe even into season two
to resolve the scene between rhaenys and rhaenyra
is just meant to show you that rhaenys definitely
knows what's really up like she understands and
she kind of goes along with it because she loves
her son and she understands his true nature so
she's just kind of forced to go along with it
low-key which she talks about to corlys later
in the episode like look we're alone together
we can admit the truth to each other it's also
why she wants corlys to name Laena's daughters
as the heirs to driftmark because they are a pure
velaryon blood laenor seems like he's so sad he's
just gonna walk out into the middle of the sea
when rhaenyra says that he's grown so despondent
that he's basically going to become useless in
their marriage what she's mostly worried about
even though she does kind of care about laenor is
that he'll eventually grow so careless that their
secret really will be found out and it'll just
cause way more problems later on all the weird
energy between rhaenyra and Daemon early in the
episode it just meant to foreshadow the chemistry
that they've always had going back to the first
episode like this always kind of had that weird
thing going on between that weird energy together
until they actually do get together later in the
episode and then officially get married viserys
and Daemon remark on the past 10 years between
them all the drama this happened how the gods have
been cruel to both of them the whole thing with
Daemon not wanting to come back to King's Landing
immediately like rejoin court immediately is
because yeah he's a little too proud he's still a
little bitter about what happened but also because
he gets remarried to rhaenyra and rhaenyra is
on Dragonstone so he goes to Dragonstone instead
obviously his whole comment to Otto Hightower
about leeches growing fatter and always wanting
more is just a callback to viserys's leeches
in earlier episodes that they tried to heal his
wounds with and also him understanding that he's
trying to influence things for his own cause for
the greens like this is the Game of Thrones
and game recognizes game I know exactly what
you're doing the real short scene of viscera's
confusing alicent for his his previous wife Aemma
is also just meant to show you how his mental
capacity is diminishing and also he's hooked
up on a lot of milk of the poppy at this point
probably that'll become a bigger thing in future
episodes that we'll talk about that will lead to
more dire consequences like imagine if everybody
listens to what the king says and if the king's
mental capacity just deteriorates enough and he
says something he doesn't mean to it could have
dire consequences I also love the scene here of
Otto Hightower just kicking aegon the second
like he's the Future King but he's still kind
of kicking him up like get up get out of here
like I said earlier aegon really loved to drink
when he was younger that only gets worse so
like this will be a bigger thing in future
episodes when we see the older version of aegon
II then the whole scene between Corlys Velaryon
and his wife rhaenys is him just trying to come
to terms with the truth of the matter like he's
so obsessed with the iron throne in this idea of
justice for his family because of what happened to
his wife being denied the Iron Throne back during
the Great Council of 101 AC then it just blinds
him to the present day truth she only cares about
her family her granddaughters now and that's why
she's talking to him about passing drift Mark
to them it's also interesting to note that she
really doesn't like Daemon she really just cares
about her granddaughters and her granddaughters
are Daemon's daughters which means that she's
kind of forced to accept Daemon it's just a
way to show you that his battle lines are being
drawn like Team Green Team blacks are starting to
form not everybody within each faction loved
each other so like all the blacks supporting
rhaenyra didn't automatically love each other the
same thing with the greens we get that scene with
Daemon and raniera and a lot of it is referencing
their history together going back to those first
couple of episodes when she was younger especially
when she references him abandoning her like you
abandoned me metaphorically and literally that's
a reference to what happened in flea bottom but
also eventually later in life when he was banished
by viserys he didn't have much of a choice like he
actually got banished from court so he couldn't
stick around and help her as much as he wanted
properly and also there's the whole idea that he
is also obsessed with the iron throne in whether
or not he chills on that because it seemed like
in last week's episode he kind of given that up
like he didn't want to go back to court I don't
want to deal with all that politicking all that
drama let's just forget about it but but it seems
like Godfather style raniera is the one to bring
him back into the family like I need your help
we need more Valyrian blood we need to Fight Fire
with Fire which like I said is also a reference
to fighting dragons with other dragons and the
only people that can do that are Dragon seeds the
Dragon Riders really interesting history too she
clarifies a couple details she said that she and
laenor velaryon actually did try to conceive they
consummated the marriage and tried a couple times
but they did not wind up conceiving which is why I
think that when Rainer and Daemon wind up getting
it on after this when she's like I'm not a child
anymore I think because of the timing of the
birth of their first child together like I said
more children get born in the future they wind up
having more children together I think because of
the timing of the birth of her first child with
him they probably conceived this night on the
beach she also mentions the curse of harrenhal
again I explained that in last week's episode
in one of my separate videos that continues to
be a thing throughout history up to the events
of the main show later in the timeline everyone
who becomes the Lord and Lady of parenthal die
some tragic and mysterious death so as crazy as it
seems like Polaris strong is right now influencing
things from before because he is the Lord of
Herron hall now he's probably going to wind up
dying some crazy death then this whole part of
the episode that takes place on the beach in the
middle of the night I'm sure people are going to
be posting memes about this for a while like this
is the darkest that you get in Game of Thrones you
know crank up the brightness setting as much as
possible on this episode to see if you can pick
out the details in the background but obviously
the big thing here is Aemond claiming vegar and I
love the way that he drops the F-bomb right after
Daemon and rhaenyra's love scene Elsewhere on the
same Beach like right as that's happening he drops
an F-bomb very apropos the reason the netting is
covering Veigar is because Laena probably added
it it looks kind of like fisherman's knot so she
probably added it so that she could Mount vhagar
way back when she was younger when she first
claimed her if it wasn't clear vhagar is the
female dragon the words Aemond keeps speaking
to her in High Valyrian are for her to be calm
because she almost roasts him too when she purrs
and he flies on her even though they treated in a
kind of funny way with him almost falling off and
screaming the whole time that sort of seals the
deal like she is officially his dragon now when
he says so vase too that also basically means go
like go vegar go a lot of the scenes of him on the
back of the Dragon trying to figure it out almost
falling off is a good way to show you what their
dragon battles will be like during the actual
Dance of the Dragons next season like it'll be a
lot of this in the sky with a bunch of different
people fighting each other on Dragon back you also
notice the way she flies is a lot different than
the other dragons so the whole idea is that she's
gotten so big and so old that it's way harder for
her to like just physically take off but when she
is in the sky she's kind of like a B-52 bomber so
once she gets her claws on you so to speak it's
done it's over the younger smaller dragons are
way faster way more nimble you also notice when
they're flying his theme song on vhagar is sort
of like a version of Daenerys theme music combined
with the main Game of Thrones theme song then they
have the whole battle with the girls aemond and
the boys baela and rhaena come to wake up jaecerys
and lucerys Daemon and rhaenyra also kind of take
notice of what's going on and when Aemond walks
back in like a boss like haha make fun of me now
I finally have a dragon no more flying pigs for
me rhaena is the one yelling at him because she's
the only one at this point besides baby Joffrey
who doesn't have a dragon and she wanted to claim
vhagar because it was her mother's Dragon there's
no real hard and fast rule about who can claim
dragons within the Targaryen family because up
to this point there hadn't been that many dragons
that many people to worry about up to the time of
Jaeherys. Jaeherys had like a ton of kids but most
of them had died off so it wasn't that big of an
issue now you have a point where there are many
Dragon Riders on both sides and everybody wants
a dragon and they're just a couple people left
who haven't claimed one yet currently now rhaena
is the only one who's not a baby that doesn't have
a dragon that'll change eventually and we'll have
more time jumps so more kids will be born and
you'll have more Dragon Riders more Dragons by
the end of the series we'll be up to like 17
dragons total but I think we're only going to
see nine total during season one they have the
whole scene where Aemond winds up losing his
eye paying off Heleana's Dragon Dream he'll have
to lose an eye and then we have that whole scene
of alicent versus rhaenyra with both of them
kind of going mom brain in trying to to deal
with the actual lie about them being bastards and
her getting Vengeance for aemond the way the show
owner said that they're playing this like with
all the different characters is basically what
aegon explains to viserys during the episode like
look at him we all know the truth the whole idea
is that the entire realm basically knows that
they are the strong boys but because the King
Viserys has declared that they're not bastards
nobody can say anything otherwise so there's
this weird tension in the realm like well if the
king forced us to accept them as legitimate that
means that they're legitimate but we know that
they're bastards even though the circumstances
a little bit more contentious on this show
with the bastard so to speak the strong boys
they actually did legitimize bastards during the
events of Game of Thrones Daenerys legitimized
Gendry is a proper Baratheon and if you remember
Ruth Bolton legitimized Ramsay so that he became
a Bolton as well also before Rob Stark died he
tried to legitimize Jon Snow but obviously he
died so then it was kind of forgotten about and I
think the whole idea with viserys is that he knows
what's actually going on like he he understands
from all the looks that everyone gives each other
and the way they talk about things that Aemond
and aegon both heard the talk about them being
bastards from their mother alicent but viserys is
trying to keep the good times rolling so to speak
like he's a peacetime King and he doesn't want the
realm to descend into war so he's willing to bend
over backwards as much as he has to to keep the
peace so that's why later in the carriage on the
way home after things get real crazy he's like
we will speak no more of this but by the time
alicent goes at rhaenyra they've both gone full
mom brain like clearly rhaenyra is overplaying
her hand like ah treason how dare they talk
about them as bastards everybody knows that
they're bastards and obviously alicent going full
mom brain is like no no no we have to take one of
their eyes like she even tries to get Criston
Cole to go cut out one of luceris's eyes even
though Criston Cole has become a full-on trash
bag at this point he's not that big of a trash
bag yet so he denies her request at the end of
the episode when rhaenyra is talking to Daemon
about the other side being worried of what they
might be capable of that's also a reference to
both of the sides the green and the Blacks doing
way worse things to each other in the future like
if you think that what's happened so far is bad
just wait to the crazy stuff that they get up
to in the future Laris strong is ready to help
out when that comes also when Kristin Cole tells
viserys the King's Guard have never had to defend
the prince from other princes that's another
reference to the divided allegiances within the
family the blacks versus The Greens when viserys
basically says that he's going to cut the tongue
out of anyone who dares question rhaenyra's Sons
as bastards anymore that's just the end of that
particular matter so the only way to solve things
now will be for things to escalate like as much
as it seems like he's wrapping up that problem
technically it made things worse she winds up
yanking the valyrian dagger off of his belt not
really knowing the history of the context behind
it because viserys has told her a lot of stories
about ancient valyria his special model he loves
telling stories about his model he hasn't revealed
aegon's secret to her because she is not the
heir it also means that he hasn't told the
secret to aegon II I think the reason why Daemon
stopped Criston Cole from stopping the fight is
is because Daemon wanted to let things play out
in Littlefinger style take advantage of the chaos
in the future like oh no no we want this to play
out when she cuts rhaenyra I think that's also
on accident like she's kind of remorseful about
that part but she does come clean with rhaenyra
about why she's been so pissed off at her and
Auntie rhaenyra these past 10 years and it's all
because she is like team rules team status quo
I've done everything that everybody told me to
do I've followed all the rules and you're getting
away with everything like nobody cares about it
she talks about creating her own brand new status
quo that's also what Daenerys talked about during
the main Game of Thrones series too I will create
a new order and alicent is all about tradition
like we've always done things this way we need to
follow the rules that everybody's been following
for all this time and that's the foundation of
their division so the whole idea here is that
alicent doesn't want Power because she's greedy
or she doesn't want the iron throne for herself
she just wants things to continue being the way
that they've always been the other thing that's
going on here too is what's happening between
the kids which is like a whole separate a thing
the whole idea is that Aemond says you know what
I lost an eye that kind of sucks but I came out
on top because I got a dragon the show Hunters
have also said that they're trying to explore
the generational aspect of these conflicts and the
way that the adults passed their beef on to their
children like the children don't actually hate
each other they just fight the way that normal
children fight every once in a while so the whole
idea is that alicent and raniera kind of low-grade
poison their children against each other so like
the whole blacks versus The Greens wasn't really a
thing amongst the children until the adults made
it that way during their conversation they also
want to let you know that rhaenyra did care about
laenor and they want to make laenor seem like a
generally good dude like he loved their kids he's
willing to give up everything that he wants in
order to support her and she's trying to do him
a solid by finding a way out of this creating a
solution that will give them both what they want
which is why they actually changed the book ending
for laenor's character in the books the maesters
recorded that he died in an accident and obviously
that's the way they play it during this episode so
the whole realm thinks that he died in an accident
when he really actually got away to the east I'll
address that in a second too because there is the
question of his Dragon seasmoke rhaenerya watches
vhagar leave the island with aemond and the other
two dragons are probably sunfyre aegon's dragon
and dreamfyre Heleana's Dragon. Larys Strong
creeps up to alicent like a spider obviously
referencing the future crazy things that they will
get up to in the shadows like oh if she'd ever
need me I have a lot of discretion I'd be happy to
get an eye for an eye and then rhaenyra basically
proposes marriage to Daemon and explains the plan
to get rid of laenor or help him escape basically
get rid of the problem of their marriage like she
says the sea offers escape that's basically a
reference to him escaping at Sea love the way
that she also starts speaking with him in High
Valyrian again like their special secret language
of love she references aegon the conquer and his
Sister Wives proposing that they get married and
in a lot of cultures the more powerful person in
a relationship will have to be the one to propose
so for instance like in real life Queen Elizabeth
II had to be the one to propose marriage to King
Philip what a coincidence because raenyra is
the heir she's more powerful politically than
Daemon and she's also trying to convince him to
join forces with her like we need to Fight Fire
with Fire you control a dragon a lot of fire and
the way they talked about their relationship in
the past the past 10 years like both of us have
experienced a lot of tragedy a lot of crap they
both seem like their happiest together like the
whole idea that they actually love each other
and I think the other big surprise here at the
end of the episode is that the whole idea behind
fake killing laenor like him faking his death is
rhaenyra's idea it's not Daemon's idea which you
would normally expect of him his whole speech to
rhaenyra about being a powerful ruler being feared
but not being a tyrant is a reference to megor
the cruel and if it wasn't clear from the act
that Qarl Correy and laenor put on laenor was very
much in on this whole plan so like he kind of over
acted a little bit like they kind of handed up a
little bit we need to put on a show so everybody
thinks that we killed each other and if it wasn't
clear the body's on the fire were the bodies of
the person that Daemon killed in the hallway and
the other person that was in the hall when they
fought they didn't have DNA records back then so
that's how they were able to get away with this
the other reason why laenor winds up shaving
his head is so that he can't be immediately
identified like wow you have white valyrian hair
that means that you're probably from one of these
two families there's also the question of what
happens to his Dragon sea smoke because he's
not dead and he didn't basically get rid of sea
smoke so I think sea smoke follows him to the east
but he just doesn't ride sea smoke for a while to
avoid any undue attention but eventually the idea
is that he might return later in the story like
way later in the story then rhaenyra and Daemon
bind their blood metaphorically and literally in
the High Valyrian custom in the outfits they're
wearing look kind of like the dragon Handler's
outfits because they follow Valyrian Customs
these are meant to be valyrian outfits it also
kind of seems like they're cutting each other
with dragonglass by their powers of twinsest and
sister wiving combined it was a great episode
obviously he's only going to get crazier from
here if you spotted any other Easter eggs or
references in the episode that I didn't talk
about in the video just write down below in
the comments my episode 8 trailer video will post
next everyone click here for that I'll update the
link as soon as I post it and click here for
my house of the Dragon aegon's Conquest video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!